CBS News contributor Bob Schieffer has
covered nine presidents including one
who was impeached and another who
resigned he's with us from Washington
Bob good morning good morning yeah I
know you watched this as well and let's
just first talk about just the simple
headline of what happened yesterday the
former FBI director who has served
Republicans and Democrats accusing the
President of the United States of lying
about him and the FBI historic it was
extraordinary I mean I guess there's
nothing new Under the Sun I I was around
here back when President Nixon made that
famous speech on television and said the
American people need to know your
president is not a crook I thought I
would never hear a president say
something like that and then fast
forward do yesterday I'm watching you
and Gail and and Charlie cover this
special report and here's Charlie and
right across the screen as a graphic
that says the president is not a liar
which is was quoting Sarah Huckabee
there I mean who would imagine that we
would see something like this in
American life but this is where we are
right now the interesting thing Bob is
they say it's just really beginning Bob
Woodward's here and said only 5% we only
know five to 10 percent up what we ought
to know of what we will know about the
Russian probe you know my general rule
is when things look pretty bad from what
we know it's usually worse
that's generally been my observation and
watching these things over the years but
this is extremely serious I mean the
Russians there's no question the
Russians meddled in our election process
they're trying to destroy our faith in
our institutions and you say can that be
right yes all you have to do is look at
what's going on in Central Europe this
is now the Kremlin playbook they don't
drive tanks across the borders anymore
it's a lot cheaper to use cyber to bribe
local officials to disrupt elections to
arrest in silence the media this
is what the Russians are doing right now
and one hopes is as we move through this
investigation will begin to understand
that because we have to start making
preparations now for how do we how do we
defense against this in 2018 when the
next election comes along this is
serious business and I do not know one
single person who deals in foreign
policy or national security right now
who does not think the Russians did and
tried to disrupt this election I'd like
to know your take though Bob on the
overall hearing team Trump says that he
was vindicated they want to move forward
with his agenda others say that mr.
Comey was professional that he was
passionate that he was calm and poised
under fire was there a winner or a loser
here in your opinion no but what what's
interesting here I mean we'll decide I
mean the public it'll decide if there
was a winner or loser because it comes
down to do you believe former director
Comey or do you believe the president's
lawyer and frankly what's happened here
is the the White House team is simply
taking the line none of it happened it's
all a lie and it's down to what he said
he said now here's what's going to
happen the special counsel is going to
continue this investigation he does have
subpoena power I take it from yesterday
when when the White House denied that
the president said any of this to me
that says there are no White House tapes
if there were tapes there are not tapes
anymore I think that's one thing we can
draw from this Bob I keep thinking and
watching all this it's more than just
about who's winning and losing it's
about the integrity of institutions the
integrity of the White House the
integrity of the FBI independent people
public servants who spend their entire
life not making a lot of money by making
it okay living in service to their
country and their reputation well again
this is what the Russians are doing not
just here but around the world they have
figured out how to use cyber how to go
in and bribe local officials in
countries across Europe how to make
sweet financial deals and loans
to to people in these Central European
countries entrepreneurs and before you
know it they have taken over the country
and that is what is so serious about all
this and that is what we have to focus
on in one hopes that as the special
council is able to delve into more of
what actually happened here that that
this will become something that will
make the public aware of what's going on
you know we know that the the Trump
people were talking to the people in in
Russia talking to the Russian ambassador
and all that we do not know specifically
what they said but call me knows and now
a Muller will soon know because there
are tapes of those conversations I think
what we find from those tapes is going
to is going to determine where all this
goes from here the bottom line this is
not over
all right Bob Schieffer thank you very
much always good to see you